[موسيقى]
اليوم العالمي للمرأة هو يوم
يحتفل فيه بالكفاح من أجل الوصول إلى المساواة بين
الجنسين ، ويحدث الاحتفال هذا العام
في وقت الحرب في أوكرانيا ،
ويجب أن يظل الرجال في سن القتال في
البلاد الآن ولكن وفقًا
لوزارة الخارجية الأوكرانية 15
الجنود الذين يقاتلون في الحرب ضد
روسيا هم من النساء ، أولئك الذين ليسوا
أعضاء رسميين في القوات
المسلحة قد تلقوا دورات تدريبية مكثفة في القتال
لحماية منازلهم ، كما تقوم بعض النساء
بحماية أطفال غرباء مثل
ناتاليا أبيلايفا الذين عبروا الحدود
إلى المجر
مع أطفال رجل  الذين لم يتمكنوا من
مغادرة أوكرانيا ، لقد سلمتهم بأمان
إلى والدتهم ،
إنه في مدينة ليفي الغربية
، اختارت بعض النساء البقاء
لدعم أحبائهم الذين
يقاتلون في الحرب ومساعدة أولئك
الذين يفرون
بشكل جيد ، دعنا نجلب الأوكرانية
السياسية التي حملت السلاح
للدفاع عن العاصمة كييف من
الغزو الروسي هي كيرا روديك
زعيمة جزء جولوس.  Y واليوم
أيضًا مقاتلة في الحرب ، انضمت إلي الآن.
على الحدود أو البقاء
للقتال كما
قررت البقاء ، قررت أن تتعلم
كيفية استخدام البندقية ، لماذا
اتخذت هذا القرار
الذي تعرفه في اليوم الأول من الحرب ، اجتمعنا جميعًا
مع أعضاء حزبي
وقررنا أننا سنكون كذلك  فعل
أه أن اختيارنا لما يجب أن
نفعله سيكون مرتبطًا بكيفية أن
نكون أكثر فائدة لبلدنا أكثر
فائدة لوطننا الأم ،
لذلك أنا الأكثر فائدة هنا
حيث يمكنني حمل السلاح ويمكنني تحفيز
الآخرين على القيام بذلك  نفس الشيء
يمكنني التأكد من أن لدى بوتين عدد أكبر بكثير من
الأشخاص ليقاتلوه مما كان
يعتقد في الأصل أنه سيكون لديه لأنه إلى
جانب الرجال الأوكرانيين ، هناك نساء
يقفن ويحملن السلاح ويضيفن
إلى هذه الأرقام لأننا
قوة هائلة ونحن شجعان للغاية